all right thank you thanks a lot the
organizers for this wonderful weekend
giving me the opportunity to to speak
and to be the last so it's the challenge
trying to entertain you I think if you
go to see fara Williams tonight is going
to be more entertaining but for the time
being I changed the title of my talk
compared to the region schedule just
because I initially thought about
talking about about cancer mutations and
this kind of thing but there has been so
many amazing talks that I thought my
talk was kind of you know not as good
and in the last 10 t2 is something
different so I just try to talk a bit
about about more general things about
gnashing running we heard I think was it
been awesome on saying yesterday that
for some computational cancer burgee is
machine learning because we do so much
of data-driven approaches we start from
data we try to learn models and we hope
they will work there was not so much
machine only this week so I thought that
is one won't talk ready to that would be
nice and in particular trying to express
so I walk in this field and try to to
this person I feeling that there are
many open questions and varnish and salt
problem that probably some people need
to address in the learning part in a
penalty of how smart we are in designing
features and diffusion and recovering at
subtypes all right so let me let me just
motivate a talk about I will not go to
two technical applications a lot
specific answer cetera but just try to
give some broad pictures of the problems
we may want to sall so typically what 11
application of what we do is improving
cancer treatments and these this can be
achieved by having better diagnosis
having better prognosis meaning about
predicting the risk of relapse etcetera
hopefully is at some point being able to
predict if if a drug will walk on a
patient so predict drug response so all
these things are are usually important
problems and ideally here are just this
is a very old picture but I yield the
one approach would say well we have a
patient we we measure whether we can
measure with sequins and from these we
put in a computer and the smart computer
we tell us well for this passion don't
do anything or give that rag or follow
this treatment that will be a dream that
perhaps would be
shivved in 20 years but for that we need
to solve the problem of how we go from
the data we measure to the decision or
the prediction so one approach to do
that is is data-driven and it's you know
so here I just focus on a binary
phenotype let's say responds are not to
a drug machine so machine learning is
the discipline that tries is one
disciplina tries to address this saying
if you call a data about samples and
let's say samples respond not to attract
then you can plot the same balls in a
space it was here I have 19 patients on
which I'm is your two genes I can plot
each patient in a two dimensional space
I call all the ones that respond or not
and then you instantly see that it's
easy to see there is a difference
between the responders and the
non-responders so you can run a rule and
then when you have new patients would
make a prediction right this is a
cartoon example of what machining could
be about and the way to solve to find
these designs are many ways are many
algorithms that you know that you've
heard of you can make your neural
networks random forests political
machines that so whatever some methods
for example you know I just write a few
equations but to learn a line you you
optimize over the set of linear
functions over the set of lines the
functions that best separate the black
from the whites okay you'll find some
objective function you minimize it you
get a classifier this will be your your
predictor idea okay so this part is
pretty much solve locator is not it has
been solved for decades there is no no
question about that now what's not
competitive solve this is when you
reverse a bit the numbers and you don't
have 19 patients in two dimensions that
you have like two patients in nineteen
dimensions or to be more realistic you
use sample you know your sequence
patients and you end up with let's say
if you're lucky thousands tens of
thousands perhaps hundreds of thousands
of patients on which you measure
millions billions of markers okay so the
ratio number of samples of our dimension
or number of markers is inverse compared
to the 22 19 ratio okay and this thing
is is becomes a difficult problem from
purely statistical reasons okay in terms
of learning is just hard to learn when
you have just a few samples and many
dimensions so there is a
lot of work many people are interested
in this problem because it's not only in
biology but in any fields we have many
features vulnerable samples and there
are many sport techniques that that try
to address this problem however its
first so that is not there is no magic
magic tool that solved this problem and
probably depending on the data we have
depending on applications some methods
will walk the methods will not work and
it's still not very clear what works and
what doesn't work like features
direction or these kind of things there
is no general recipe okay so something
that that that the thing i will discuss
now is one approach want one which is
quite trendy i would say if you've heard
of deep learning all the things is an
approach that says well when you have
data soda planning is more but images or
text but you're assuming we have this
data there's a question of how can we
change the representation of our data
and instead of directly working with the
raw data so instead of saying we have a
patient which is a set of numbers what I
measure and I make a linear function on
that to make my prediction what about
changing the representation meaning
going from the raw data to some other
representation which could be a vector
which could be something else so you
change your data to something else and
then you run something on this new
representation okay so this is something
quite intuitive it's something like it
could be like one approach would be to
say well what about reducing the
donation if I complain about the
dimension being too high I could try to
say to do much insulation saying that
instead of all the thousands of of
measures I just focus on 10 of them I
have to choose it and then the station
is easier so feature session is one way
to change a plantation there are other
ways that we've heard a lot about this
week like if you have you know the
mutation spectrum of patients instead of
working directly with that first do a
smoothing on graph you get a new
presentation and you have the discipline
tation be better to make a model against
kind of thing so more generally you
could ask well how to change your
presentation and when you think of that
it means what would be a good
representation it will be representation
that keeps the signal or improve the
signal the burgee called signal that
would
allow you to make a prediction that's
one thing and the second thing you want
the new presentation to be unable to do
machine learning algorithms like you
want representation where learning is
easy okay and so this this part of our
you you you go from the rotator to data
where you can learn a good model I think
is very open field where which is very
active nowadays not only biology but in
other application domains so we'll to
make this a bit more concrete I would
just now discussed two things which are
by no means representative of the
generality of this approach but at least
try to give some insight of how we can
think of new presentations of the data
that sometimes may may allow to to
improve the learning and therefore the
performance of the model okay I know
that they want to make a good prediction
then this is what our focus maybe as
opposed to trying to understand the full
biology yeah I'm just talking of how can
we make a model that predicts well what
we want to predict so I will talk of
quickly very quickly of two things one
George walk with marine gave a talk
yesterday on how you can unite
supervised normalization of your data
and the second will be about how can you
learn from I mean change your data by
doing pairwise comparison between your
markers so I start with a quaint
atomization so you should set up a
that's not very interesting you know
when you do machine on you first want to
have good data you have that someone
before us process the data you know as
made the bad work of going from the raw
data to data you can use and then you
run your model or you do your diffusion
or you you know you you train your
things now what is four point a
normalization this is something that
that is done are thinking in not always
but in many data that we use is simply
the idea that suppose so this is a total
picture again we're suppose each box
plot on the top picture is a set of
markers a set of numbers you measure on
on different samples so samples could be
patient so you have here you have each
each particles is a patient you do RNA
seek or drunk transcriptomics you
measure the the expression of all the
genes and usually when you compare the
patient's you see you have huge batch a
face you see you have many things that
that
viendo do they make the distributions of
the values very different okay so you
could just say like that and if you stay
at that you do clustering and you see
very clearly the batches the the
non-magical effect so you would like to
remove that one way to remote that is
not always done but one common way to
that's say well first for each patient
is try to you know try to normalize the
data so that they are the same coverage
or the same average or make something
comparable and for example full quaint
organization is a very strong processes
let's impulse that each patient after
normalization as the same distribution
of values okay so it's easy to do the
way to do is for each patient you have
let's say your 10,000 measures you rank
them for all of the patients and then
you choose a target distribution that
would be the distribution after the
novelization and once you have the
targets mission you just modify the
values you had before memorization so
that they have the same ranking the same
order of the other features but they fit
the distribution you want okay and so
often this is done there is a question
which is what what should be then your
target distribution because everybody's
number is the same one so it could be
usually the average distribution of all
the guys but it seems to be arbitrary it
could be whatever but at least you you
end up with things that you have so when
you're that you see you have changed
representation of your data and the hop
here is that you have removed a bad
signal like technical artifice and you
have that you have cadbury called signal
so it's a bit in this idea to say let's
change representation in order to learn
from data which are better it turns out
that this thing could be important and
here we just I will not repeat all but
this is a slide that marine showed
yesterday so in fact this work was
motivated by this application were to
make a long story short here the goal
was to train a model to predict survival
of cancer patients for mutations okay so
you have mutations you want to make a
model to produce survival I skip all the
technical details but the take-home here
was that if you walk on the raw data so
you have a rate of binary binary vector
of mutations is very hard to run the
model because there is not enough
overlap between the patient's so you get
bad performance on the
beta now a nice ID you do a diffusion of
a protein-protein interaction network
then suddenly needs nice because you
know it's motivated because you have
mutations in genes which work together
so as soon as you defuse you start to
get overlap and you can have that it
improves it improves a bit it's called
NS here so he doesn't improve at all you
can cruise a bit but you see it's not
something is still missing and now you
know the devil is in the detail is what
i call the machining part which plays a
role if then instead of just the network
smoothing you do cuenta full point our
normalization which is done in the
middle packages which are used sometimes
they are not very much highlighted in
the in the publications but the other
because otherwise doesn't work then you
get to boost in performance okay so just
to say that the simple like let's say
the idea of of smoothing is great but to
make it work you need to combine it with
some purely mathematical artifacts so
that the running can occur okay and in
fact if you change the normal if you
still do for grant animation with a
different target distribution you can
still improve artist get different
results so here I just want say that you
know whatever these results this is the
part of thing that's often hidden from
the you know is how to understand why
why it works away it doesn't work but
it's my experience is that when you run
these big black box models high
dimensional models sometimes the reasons
why they work or not is is a bit hard to
get and sometimes it's not only what
features you get a minimal you may have
very nice ideas off we need to get these
features about in directions about these
days but at least you get the good
performance there are a few things which
are still very fuzzy in this case the
way you normalize your data plays a
major role in the performance of the
model all right so you could say well
here you know I took mutation data I
diffuse i canta normalize it works but
as i said there are different ways to
the point atomization you can choose for
example the target distribution so you
may say well if i contain normalize to
get the gaussian distribution will it
work better or if i keep the average
distribution of the data is it better or
if I just threshold like a you know very
what married in a very
no magician does it work so it raises a
question which is could we optimize the
way we normalize the data and perhaps
not do that independently from what we
do afterwards not going from raw data to
normalize and then something that joint
everything so this is a thing that that
which was also the question now is what
would be a good criterion a good idea on
how to optimize the target distribution
and one idea and I'm sorry for for the
equations i miss a bit late in the week
but here it's just the idea will be say
well if you say if you think of going
from raw data doing full content
normalization and then learning a model
let's say a linear model in this case
which includes support vector machines
or survival logistic regression or less
or whatever so here you run the model
the idea is that what you want to do is
to learn alena model so here that the
parameters in my questions are W and B
so this is arena model w X plus B this
would their inner function and instead
of running it on the raw data you want
to learn it on the data which have been
transformed by full content
normalization and here i just write a
small F to indicate that F would be the
target distribution so usually what we
do is we fix her F and we solve that to
normalize and then learn model one ID to
you know to automatically choose what
would be the best distribution we'd say
well what about including F here so the
target distribution as part of the
objective function and saying let's join
to optimize the way we normalize
followed by the way we need a linear
model so that at the end we optimally
predict survival for example that's all
so it's just the idea to link together
the normalization and during our model
so connecting two functions because
function off exactly so I come to that
so it's really different from saying I'm
optimizing one over one function that is
no so I contact to the next time you
would see it's very generally it's not
very new it just ok let me continue next
time so yeah I just add I'd here just
added f I just say let's optimizer w an
F and Alex a well so let's let's ride it
a bit differently to see if this is not
something already done or not in fact
it's not it's not very complicated to
see that doing a quantum normalization
is just in fact doing a matrix product
meaning that if you have a sample X I
said that matrix multiplication is is
two things first you rank the features
of the sample and then you give them the
values of F ok so this you can write as
if I have a sample I rang them I put
them in what's called a permutation
matrix so this is a square matrix that
where which is binary with you know just
one pero and / colon and the one says
that the ice feature is ranked at the JC
position ok so if you replace your
sample eggs by this matrix by eight then
the operation of containerization is
just multiplication on the right by the
target distribution this gives you the
normalized feature and then the linear
model is just multiplication of this on
the left by a vector W so you can
combine all together and we interpret
this thing as just saying that what you
have extracted from the original data is
just the permutation matrix so each
sample from the raw data is transformed
into a ranking of its obvious feature
and doing a linear model over and
optimized full grant anomalous data is
just making a linear model over this
matrix just because you can play with
the matrices ok so as you were saying
this is something which you know it's
not completely new you can recall that a
linear model over a new representation
of your data which is the permutation
matrix with a few constraints which is
that this design our model so you know
it is in the space of matrices so it
turns out that it's a rank one matrix so
it's a constraint in our model in
addition which could have specially
Caesar usually the target solution has
to be
increasing to be a submission so it's a
kind of variant of linear models where
it Selena model of our matrices of with
rank run model that has the property
that the F value is increasing okay so
i'm not sure is very standard but at
least just just a different way to learn
a model right so this thing is not easy
to optimize just because it's not
convinced because of the rank one
constraints or the end of the day what
we do is just too greedy approach where
we optimize fw fw converges to a local
minimum and it gives in principle effing
aw that that is jointly normalized a
target distribution anal in our model to
try to predict survival if we focus on
survival all right so this is a this is
very mature very much work in progress
so I don't have any what the first thing
you can say that it doesn't work very
well I mean we tried it with hot and you
know sometimes it works magically
sometimes it does not so you know after
spending a few hours we can get some
curves that start showing that on some
data sets if you're careful you can
improve the performance he was sorry
what this shows is each curve is shows
the performance of the model after
number of iterations so black is you
training on the raw data and then there
is a curve to which is once you do one
iterations of optimizing W&F and you
were too noisy situate will converge
something this is concordance index on
some breast cancer thing that you know
there is no strong message here just
that after struggling a bit with
something we managed to get something
that does a bit better than the row
later but its first say I mean marinas
new results that it's not magic doesn't
work very well but at least it's an idea
to you know that could be was
investigating as a tool to try to change
the plantation and say well what about
including normalization in the running
process okay so so let me move on to it
I mean that it was done before but if
condition as a follow-up of this in fact
what we have done here so unison that
these
optimization of the of the quantile
function any number doll is equivalent
to walk in with a representation of your
data we're on a sample once you have the
measures what you keep is just the order
order features ok it was the match with
the permutation matrix so it's as if you
are saying I measure many things on a
patient I rang them and I do something
out of this of this rank so this could
be a so this decided to rank features
and work on the ranking could be
beneficial for machine learning just
because you mean you remove the
continuous aspect of the features and
you move so you would you you know you
move your sample to a discrete space the
space of all possible orderings color is
your group the permutation group so it's
a discrete object and you know in some
situations the learning problem may be
easier in these discrete space than in
the continuous original space of vectors
so sorry me any quickly discuss whether
there are other things that you can do
once you if you decide to first you know
a strike from the data just the ordering
of the markers of the features and then
do machining on that what else can you
do instead of supervised quintal
normalization so in fact the ID to look
at ranks is not you and I would just
mention a line of world by done gman and
some follow-up on predictor so this is
all you know 10 years all the work but I
think still relevant in magnifications
where as opposed to making big model big
linear model with 70 jeans etc or more
or black box svms for classification of
microarrays there's been a few
interesting results where in order you
know suppose you are you measure gene
expression of samples and you want in
this case to this human eye between this
is very old and classical example this
human between two types of leukemias
based on gene expression it has been
found that sometimes with very simple
classifiers based on pairwise
comparisons you get good results so
pairwise comparison is that we
discriminate between these two
categories which would be the black and
the white points instead of making a
linear model on the jeans you just have
a rule something like is gene a larger
than gene be or the other way okay
it's a pair so the benefit of that one
benefit is that this this kind of rule
is independent on systematic bash a
phase that would increase or decrease
all values like the pairwise comparisons
it could be robust to some some
technical effects and you know sometimes
it may lead to biology too so this is I
mean I do not to do that but because you
have jeans you could say well it's my
rule is based on comparing three genes
at least I have a rule that perhaps
could lead to some explanation let's say
that at least the ID to not to look at
the valve you know not to make a
predator based on the value of the gene
expression but just comparing the values
of different genes has been around for
for a while so what we what we can can
try to do now is to go a bit further and
say well what about what walking in
these representations so again for me
it's a way to say i miss your data but I
don't want to order it here too high
dimensional to complicate you to too
much noize let's try to replace this
thing by something else and in this case
that something else could be just a
binary matrix so here this is one sample
so think that each row here is a gene
okay and we place a measure of on all
the genes by a matrix where you just
compare all genes two by two so you take
gene one versus two you check which one
is the largest so if the value here is
the router are not for one or two and
you put one or zero in the in the
corresponding row and column okay so
because you have if you have P genes
then you have P times P minus 1/2
pairwise comparisons and you end up with
the representation of this vector as a
matrix of binary binary matrix of size a
P P times P okay and say well what about
walking in this representation like if I
want to make a linear model instead of
making a linear model here what about
making a linear model here just using
these features of pairwise comparison
this could be one one one approach so
again I don't claim it will work with at
least it's a change of viewpoint and
perhaps you could argue that up you know
dimension is bigger here but it's just
binary so you know there could be some
trade-off that says it may be better to
walk in with more feature with more
binary features than with
continuous features this could be trial
at least okay so let's try at least to
fill up a bit of these IDs so if you
want to do that that there is a this I
don't need there is a practical problem
which is that if you measure let's say
10,000 or 100,000 or million markers now
I say well you know you store your
million dimensional vector and first you
start by building these million by
million binary matrix before doing your
SVM or your logistic regression so it's
a bit a pain to do that you don't want
to really store these very matrices
because I just extracted from from the
raw data it seems to be a waste of
memory of time of computation etc so so
here you see you have one matrix for
each sample so if you have n samples you
have n matrices of the of times P by P
and the bees can be very large this is
our problem p the north knockers could
be very large so how can you still work
with this data while there is so this is
the good old for four people in the room
you know what we'll remember support
vector machines and carob trees etc this
is a case where in fact you can make
dinner models over these matrices using
a trick mathematical trick which is that
even though these matrices are bigger is
very efficient to directly compute their
inner product if you want so if you see
each batteries as a P times P minus 1
divided by 2 dimensional vector and you
know suppose it a two matrices these two
matrices and you want to make the inner
product you think about it d inner
product between these two matrices would
be the Sun over all the boxes here of of
the products so 1 times 1 or 1 times 0
is 0 times once so this would amount to
count how many pairs of features are
running the same the same way into two
samples and if you closely at it in fact
this thing is a very standard measure of
correlation between the two original
data called the candle talk correlation
so it's something that you know
everybody knows about you go to are you
click correlation candle you get this
and so here that the trick is just that
the candle toe is precisely the inner
product between these two presentations
okay so this is just a mathematical
fight but it's a good news for things
like spa vector machines or Ridge
regression or so no get in our cox
bundles etc because it means using some
some some treat working the draw that
you can solve the SVM without computing
these matrices that just walking with
the original data and changing the camel
you say instead of making arena or
Gaussian kernel I take the candle to
carnal and this thing will will will
allow you to very easily done Sen even
though you walk in huge dimension okay
so it's just a computational aspect of
it that that allows you to walk in high
dimension with fast computation ok so
this I think I can just keep a still
thought I would show a network because
there are many networks this week so
technical comments what I just said
could be interpreted in different ways
if you think of all you know I said
let's revisions samples or patient by
ranking of the features then you can
make so the set of rankings is huge
there are many possible permutations is
called a symmetry group in fact you got
you can you can imagine a space where
you have all the samples and you you can
connect them as soon as they have just a
pair so in this case a pair of sexy
features which are rivers flipped ok so
this thing is called the Kaylee's graph
and for people interested in this kind
of thing what I just said is that if you
take in this graph the shortest path
distance between two samples then the
shortest path distance is the number of
inversions you need to make a move from
one sample to the other so this is
exactly my candle correlation I mean 1
minus my Kindle correlation ok so what
we do in fact is that to compare two
samples we walk that we define a
distance between two samples as the
shortest path distance in this
particular graph and it to magic that
computing the shortest path distance is
so efficient even though the graph is
huge and for example there's been other
attempts machine learning to say let's
walk on this graph and define a distance
between things using the diffusion can
also the random walk ID that is very
popular in this
main that's been done but the problem is
that to compute the diffusion colonel
here takes a super exponential time
because we cannot do better than really
in a sense inverting the matrix which is
n to the n times n to the N so this is a
case where computation is much better to
walk with the shortest path distance on
this graph done with any other variant
of of distances between nodes of the
graph but you know it's not central to
the doggies watch just to comment to
have at least a network a graph on my on
my sides all right I think with just you
know illustrator out can also hear does
each work while we tested this again
it's not very hot datasets in DC longer
sir but is the you know there are
benchmarks to say well what about how do
we make models in high dimensions we
tested we compare the soul you know here
we just say well let's just change
representation so we try not to change
the learning algorithms we just took a
support vector machine and say either we
learn from the raw data or we learn with
a Gaussian kernel or we learn with this
or this all we learn with this
representation meaning the two Kendall
kernel and without you know without
trick or tuning too much turns out that
this thing is competitive it's not
significantly better but it's easily
competitive with making a linear model
on the relay tower using the Gaussian
kernel or using the top scoring pairs or
a lot of variance ok so again it's now
it's not a huge win they just say that
just this change representation it's
hard to say beforehand if it will
improve on other performance but here at
least it's very odd to make a linear
model over the binary matrix then over
the raw data ok for reasons that
probably i'll have to deal with the
complexity of the running in this space
so in the hope that we have kept in a
logical information and try to remove
the beat the noise or perhaps a decrease
the dimension alright so i think i don't
need to talk of some morally technical
details
and yeah I think I think every
everything else is just editing so my
main message here what to say well
machine learning is a nice ID but be
careful it's not it's not a salt problem
in high dimension and more importantly
my message would be you know when we
make a model we reach a performance it's
not obvious how to improve the
performance in fact you are what's the
bottleneck you know sometimes the
bottleneck is we need more data
sometimes the bottleneck is we have too
many data sometimes if we don't have the
good features and I think the this part
of understanding why why we have a limit
is important because it could help us to
sometimes improve them it sometimes
typically by doing things that seem not
to make much sense from a magical point
of view like removing important features
but just because they could help the
running process by making the you know
the ratio number of samples over
features less drastic okay I think that
that's all I wanted to say and I would
just like to thank my so in particular
marinas here and you you longer I don't
I don't seem it should be yeah you know
he's here who walked on the on the
kennel kennel and you for your attention
until the last minute Thank you Thank
You Theresa
helped with this intuition so
intuitively it's just right to move to
the round to move to the relative
informational at Frankie but if we have
a station like twist they say gene
expression when we have this block of
genes that are lonely expressed wouldn't
this introduce a lot of nice because
you'll have lots of competition so so
that we also require some sort of
filtering too but you expect the scum
the fact of the signal being compared to
like most of genes being yeah yeah yeah
so that's a very good point you know
obviously where will you take all the
wise comparisons 99% of it seems to be
nonsense probably so sorry the question
was here I in my possession I compare
all pairs of jeans okay and probably
among all the genes many of them have
nothing to do a very loudly expressed so
when you compare all pairs you could
assume like you know in my matrix this
matrix perhaps if you take a gene that
has a very low expression or noisy
expression it would just use a lot of
noise here and the amount of noise would
would be more important here than in the
original data so that's that's a good
point I don't have any strong answer to
that they said that we tried so what we
tried is typically here I did not
command but sorry purse I have one slide
yeah this kind of thing so what we said
is what about instead of taking all
pairwise comparisons to just pick the
best ones so top-scoring is the one top
pair k top-scoring the method that says
let's take ka tops currents and so we
tried you know purchased on perfect but
he's doing some feature selection of our
peers and say instead of taking
everybody take the best pairs and what
we found in terms of performance it's a
bit not a very good graph but we found
that there was no benefit in selecting
features in the space okay so this may
be do you know to the power of the SVM
twerking high dimension and be robust to
noise but but it's a very good very good
comment and we just found that there was
no benefit at all to do feature
selection perhaps the future session
selfies is a difficult problem that
that intro this is difficult
the performance IAM this one
so first question is do you have a new
video for you
that was sufficient second dictionary no
stuffy organ your color works
neighbors
usually what is reverse in my experience
son is on expression data is not this
one right on many many problems yes I
don't know if you have some particular
result in nine but you know if so the
comparison between Gaussian polynomial
and in our channel it's surprising that
in in you know at least in the in these
data sets if you systematically try you
will see that the arena kernel is very
very competitive probably it has to do
with the huge dimensions compare the
small samples and we don't you know we
cannot afford learning nonya things but
let's say you know there is not a huge
difference but at least on this data
that I would not mind furnaces that the
Gaussian kernel is not really much
better than the others but regarding the
sorry where I am yeah you not explain
what what all the violence were but so
this is just empirical finding I'm not
have no explanation for that but at
least you know if I want to explain why
we try we try typically dalinar just the
sender in our Colonel either on the
initial data or on the top was on the
pairwise comparisons we're the best were
selected with feature selection in this
case okay so well the new features is
optimized by cross-validation skate we
say so so what I call the linear tap
this is a linear SVM after feature
selection over the binary matrix okay
and the number of features itself you
know it's part of the running process so
there is inner cross-validation to
select k and etc so so it's a bit a
complicated process but this is what
I'll say it isn't it does not really
improve overtaking everybody
companies simple that's right in your
workspace is your problem space apart
more complicated than
yeah you're right but I don't know what
I mean you could say simple or you could
say that in dimension 20,000 you know
it's quite easy to separate 100 points
of course in our functions you don't
need machine nonlinearities to separate
two points in dimension 20 so it's ready
if we had you know if I think it's ready
to rate this idea of understanding what
was the bottleneck is the bottleneck to
move to Nani nap things or the bottle
night to decrease the space I think here
this is more evidence that we're at the
point where we don't need to go to more
complicated models for sure because we
cannot turn them that effect so you know
maybe you can extend some of the methods
for cases where just ranking won't solve
that effect there are many cases in the
literature and no I mean no I don't have
any particular idea i think you know but
there's a huge lecture on batch effects
so for sure here we remove some part of
problems which which just keep the
ordering so systematic things of change
all distributions is handled by doing
food container musician this year that's
why it was proposed now I would just say
you know at some point 42 to make good
normalization or to remove the things we
need to understand you know to find
directions some kind of effect on all
directions if we could find a
representation where biog is this
direction and batch of fate is this
direction then we are done because we
just focus on this direction and I agree
that the ranking is not so easy you know
it's recently so no I don't have any
magic idea
get it the soul you have two methods and
you started out by motivating we should
decrease that i mentioned of king yeah
he is too big yeah yeah yeah so does any
one of these two methods actually
increase it doesn't lie well it doesn't
it decreases it increases p but it
replaces continuous values by binary
values each of the feature space and
make it simple yeah so so typically this
is what what we do this is our initial
space so we hear it's a vector of
numbers okay so it's a P dimensional
vector and I replace it by P Square
there were one values yeah I mean it's a
possibility you know it again this is
why I say there is nice on the soft iron
here you could say it's simpler because
you you know in machine learning
statistics you can quantify that indeed
the running race all in all though the
theorems that quantify how hard it is to
learn with veena models are better here
than here ok you have you get a log
factor when you move from continues to
discrete but this is your theory ok here
the intuition I mean there is not only
the change of dimension that again the
perhaps try to find a representation
that could be more rubbers to something
that that that could post difficulty to
the raw data so i think it's a mixture
of all but it's very much open myself
and have a clear understanding of what's
happening so this is very important
and so I had a question about the
dataset you with that whether they were
micro it is that's where sequence of it
i think i'm mostly back away because i
was wondering because with sequencing
data I mean with microwaves reasonable
to assume that you're measuring each
thing recently saying variability but
with sequencing of course you get
different sequencing dobson so your
variability and how you're measuring
them from gene to gene not just across
samples but contains a very much more
yeah I thought I fully agree our game
yeah and it will be and it won't
necessarily show up in your stick across
your sample is very so you know we
didn't think partially about that that
but it's very different types of data in
I you know my idea would you say well
for different types of data is let's try
to understand what you know what was
behind it and and perhaps this idea of
finding representations of features or
systemic change of spaces latitude areas
are important so for singles i have many
zeros obviously I don't want to rank
everybody based on the zeros we need to
be smarter than that for example thank
you